The year was 1982, and two social scientists, James Q. Wilson and George L. Kelling, had just
given the world a theory that would explain more than just why neighborhoods crumble.
They called it the Broken Window Theory. Picture it, a single pane of glass, cracked and ignored,
left there, unnoticed, unfixed, and then, oh, then something shifts. The next window goes,
then the next, graffiti appears. Doors stay unlocked. Before you know it, the whole street
has surrendered to decay. But here's the thing about Broken Windows. They don't just rot buildings.
They rot relationships, and not the dramatic kind, the kind that end with screaming matches or slamming
doors. No, these are the quiet ones, the ones that fade like a photograph left in the sun.
We don't lose the people we love over grand betrayals. We lose them over the unreturned
texts, the forgotten birthdays. The way we let a joke linger too long, unanswered. Each one is a
crack in the glass, and once the first one appears, the rest follow. Now, let's talk about how to
accelerate the process. Because if you're truly committed to misery, you don't just let the windows
break by accident. You shatter them deliberately. First, there's the unreturned text. A friend reaches
out, maybe they're hurting. Maybe they just need to hear your voice. You see the notification. You
know it's there. And you do nothing. Three days pass. Then you reply, cold as a winter morning.
Sorry. Been busy. That's the first window. And once it's broken, the rest will follow.
Then comes the selective memory. Ever had an argument where you suddenly remember everything
the other person has ever done wrong. The one time they forgot your anniversary. The way they laughed
at your joke, that joke. The one you told in 2018. You dredge it all up, polished and sharp,
while their years of kindness vanish like smoke. That's the second window. And it shatters.
Next, the public slight. A misplaced fact, corrected in front of witnesses.
Actually, that movie came out in 94. A trivial error, but now it's out there.
A stain on the reputation of trust. The third window. And with each correction,
the graffiti of doubt spreads a little wider. Finally, the fixed mindset label. Someone tries
to change. Someone dares to grow. You pin them down with their past. You've always been like this.
And just like that, the door stays locked. The neighborhood empties. The silence settles in.
The genius of the broken window theory? It doesn't require force. No grand gestures.
No dramatic confrontations. You just let the decay happen. And soon, your friends,
your neighbors will realize a property value of your company has plummeted.
They'll walk away. One by one. Until you're left standing in the ruins of your own design.
A master of the social ghost town.
And the best part? You didn't even have to do the kicking out. The windows did it for you.
A single unrepaired slight is the beginning of a magnificent silence.
You just let the
That sky or whatever the fancy talent is.
Just so there's nothing to do. Forgain out there.
First humans.
Like the
avalence.
To